next we're going to go
to the
imdb
document
remember the imdb were the movie reviews
and so this is a task in document
classification
and
again
keras has this data set
we're going to use a dictionary of size
10 000 words
okay
and
if you recall
the way things work is we build a bag of
words model
where we score each document
for whether or not the words in our
dictionary appear in the document it's a
binary vector and we're going to limit
it to the 10 000 most commonly used
words in the dictionary okay and when we
extract the data set we can straight
away
indicate that and it will truncate
each little review to just using those
words
this third line here is is a shortcut
using a kind of assign operator
that
takes the imdb data structure and builds
up a train and test list and
also x and y
so these are shortcuts we learned from
the keris
keris book
let's have a look at the the indices for
the first 12 words in the first document
so there they are
so the words are indicated by positions
in the dictionary of 12 000 okay
so if you want to actually see the words
we write a decode function
and the decode function
needs to take into account certain
padding words like start and stop and
unused
and so there's some details here we
won't go into it yet now but you can
read more details in the lab
and that tells you the beginning of of
that review so it translates the numbers
into the actual words so this form was
just brilliant casting location scenery
story direction everyone so it doesn't
look like english
but
remember we limited ourselves to this
restricted dictionary
and so now
we
write a function
to one on hot encode each document in a
list of documents and return a binary
matrix in sparse matrix format
so remember this what this is going to
do is
for each document it's going to give you
a binary matrix and it's just going to
be zeros or ones
according to which words were present in
the dictionary
you see here in the last line
we made a call to the sparse matrix
function because this matrix is mostly
zeros right because any document only
has
if the document's got
you know
50 words or 100 words or whatever
there's only going to be 100 at most 100
ones in the document in in the sparse
vector and the rest are going to be
zeros
we use a matrix capital matrix package
and the sparse matrix function
to
store this matrix in a sparse format
and so this code here is setting things
up to do that
next we
we use the one hot encode function
it's telling it that there's there's
the dictionary of of length ten thousand
and uh
so we'll just run that code so all the
components of x rain get one hard
encoded
is that right yeah so this makes these
these matrices that are
i see i'm sorry i got a little lost in
in the code here so this is just a
function to do the one hot encoding
right
and it returns a sparse matrix
and here we run one hot on the training
and the test yeah
and so we see
that the dimension of the x that we have
out is 25
000 by
10 000
and
if we look at the fraction of non-zeros
we see it's
1.3 percent
we're going to sample a
validation set of size 2000
just so that we can monitor progress
and and select tuning parameters
so first we'll fit a lasso logistic
regression using the glimnet
and evaluates performance on the
validation data
and we'll we'll plot its
accuracy
as a function of the shrinkage parameter
lambda
and glimmer it will take advantage of
the sparse matrix format
because this is a pretty massive x
matrix but glimnit knows how to take
advantage of the of the sparse t he just
knows because x terrain is
it you don't tell it it just it figures
it out all right yes so if one had to
look at the class of x train you'd see
it would be a sparse matrix
yeah
should we do that yeah
so let's see
what's it x underscore
ng matrix yeah so i forget what these
things but there's a column sparse
matrix and
from the package
matrix
okay
so
there's a call to glimnet
we tell it to use a binomial because the
response remember is
the
sentiment of the of the document and it
was
what was it favorable or unfavorable
yeah
and
we tell it not to standardize the matrix
because the matrix the features are all
binary so they they all in the same
units
then we predict on the
on the test data
or in this case the validation data
and
we compute the accuracy
so let's get that running
and it's done
and in this case we just make a plot of
of the results
and
we see the performance on the
validation data
and
it gets up to about 88 percent
okay
now we're going to fit a neural network
and we'll use two hidden layers each
with 16 units
okay
so
there's a specification so this is
starting to look familiar by now
and
tell it the optimizer we tell it the
epochs batch sizes and so on so this is
just a standard two layer neural network
there it goes
what do we see there rob we see
overfitting pretty quick pretty quick
overfitting yeah
it
uh
it gets up to
about 88 just over 88 89 percent
accuracy
on on the test data but starts
overfitting fairly quickly
right
and we didn't have any dropout i see
maybe that we could have we didn't have
dropout that could have slowed the
overfitting yeah
i do recall trying some
dropout and other things here but you
know it didn't seem to make much
difference
we've just shown the validation accuracy
we'll also like to see the test accuracy
so i basically run the
the program again but this time
on the using the test data and not the
validation data
um i won't show that now